this is from a really important story
here from the new york post
it says a model has claimed that she
doesn't need a boyfriend because she's
so in love with herself
uh
luanna sandian said that she is
autosexual which is a self-love
relationship that can go beyond the
erotic sphere the divorced model adds
that she doesn't need a boyfriend to
experience sexual pleasure pleasure and
revealed that she will even be happy
enjoying valentine's day alone
um
she says being autosexual as i see it is
along the same lines as being an
independent person
luana claimed that she's not thinking
about having a relationship with someone
else at the moment she continued i found
myself single it's the best thing a
woman can do for herself
and she explains what autosexuality is
she says it means i'm attracted to
myself i always felt that way i just
didn't know there was a name for it
and then she continues and this was
interesting
it's nice to know i'm not crazy or a
massive narcissist it's something real
that a lot of people experience it was
very important to find out that i'm not
alone
as sexy as that may sound and it is it's
kind of self-love on steroids there was
always a part of me that thought it was
weird so it's nice to have this
statement that it's normal
and so we see the same process carried
out yet again which of course by the way
this it is narcissism i mean it's it's
like pretty much the definition of
narcissism
um being literally in love with yourself
i would be interested in seeing the the
headline 10 years from now
uh you know the headline now is model
claim she doesn't need a boyfriend
because she's so in love with herself
ten years from now the the headline is
x-model
says that she's alone and miserable
because of rampant misogyny you know
that's gonna be the headline 10 years
from now because the thing that these
women don't understand is that
your youth and your beauty
all of that fades
pretty quickly
and it's just one of the sad realities
of being a mortal human being
um and we're being introduced to a lot
of the realities of being a mortal human
being in the last few years and people
don't seem to like any of them and
that's just it's true a lot of it is
really not not very fun but another one
of those realities along with the fact
that you're going to
the other one is that if you live
kind of a normal length of life
most of your life you're gonna is gonna
be spent
not youthful and physically beautiful
the majority of your life
you'll you will be in that state
so what you have right now is
very temporary and very fleeting
and if that's if that's all you are
if that's the only thing you care to
cultivate
then once that goes you're gonna have
nothing
and when you're walking around now and
saying well i don't doesn't matter
because i'm i'm young i'm beautiful
i don't need to try to impress anybody i
don't need companionship with anybody
people are fawning over me
you know when you act that way
eventually that goes away you you lose
the youth and beauty but people remember
what a miserable person you are and so
you've alienated everyone in your life
you don't have your beauty to fall back
on and now you're going to spend the
rest of your life just alone miserable
and that's what it's going to be well
one thing i can tell you as a four-star
chef myself um amateur chef but i
consider myself a four-star chef your
kitchen is not complete without
great kitchen knives and that's why you
need cami kota kamikota taps into more
than 800 years of traditional techniques
from honshu japan
kamikoda also uses steel sourced for
mills in japan and each blade is crafted
using techniques that have been honed
and perfected by generations of knife
smiths each knife comes in a beautiful
heavy duty ash wood box and makes sure
that the knife is stored safely as well
each kamikota knife goes through a
rigorous 19-step process that takes
several years from start to finish to
complete our expert blade smiths forge
and shape raw steel into hardy blades uh
polishing and sharpening them to an
excruciatingly fine edge each knife is
individually inspected kamikoto is so
confident that their knives will work
for you that each knife comes with a
lifetime guarantee because of their
single bevel edge kamikoto knives can
achieve an unbelievably sharp edge you
just can't get with other knives they
can cut through your rib eye like butter
that is guaranteed uh cam koto is
currently having a massive extended new
year sale and on top of that sale you
can get an additional 50 50 off any
purchase you make with discount code
matt walsh so click the link below or go
to camacota.com matt walsh and use promo
code matt walsh to save an extra fifty
dollars today but she also says how um
how well okay i i'm in love with myself
i'm very obsessed with myself all i care
about is myself
so she's divorced her marriage didn't
work out big shocker there
and then she says that
she she went i guess on the internet as
people do
and she discovered that there's a name
for there there's a label
and that other people
feel the same way she does about
themselves
and just discovering that discovering
that she's she's not alone which is kind
of ironic because she says that she
wants to be alone yet it was she wants
to be alone she's okay being alone yet
it was very important to her
that she's not alone in feeling this
this way at the same time so she wants
to be alone but she also doesn't want to
be alone
so you find that that tension there
um and so it's important for her to find
out that there are other people
in this
quote unquote community and that there's
a label for it
and the minute you can label it
and you discover that there are other
people that carry the same label
that that in your mind that legitimizes
it and that makes it a legitimate
identity
and thus an identity that deserves to be
celebrated and probably we should take
autosexual if they're not already and
add them to the to the alphabet lgbtqia
maybe is autosexual one of the a's
that's already in there i don't know
and we see this is this is the same
process we've seen many
times where you take people they they
you know they have a a certain
compulsion
a compulsion that they should be
resisting and suppressing in her case
it's a compulsion towards obsessive
selfishness that's a it's bad okay
people might experience it but it's bad
you should try to suppress it
try to be a better person
you should try to develop some virtue
um
and maybe in a different time someone
like herself that's what she would have
done
because she would have assumed that
there's something wrong with feeling
this way she would assume that she's the
only one she was she's not going to go
out in public and talk to people face to
face and say hey i'm in love with myself
and i'm the only person i care about she
would never say that to someone
so she would feel that shame and she
would feel the need to change herself
and she would change maybe
but now because of the internet
whatever compulsion you feel you could
just go
google it
uh discover that there are other people
in that quote community
that there's even a fancy label for it
and now rather than suppressing this and
maybe getting over it and becoming a
better person now you've embraced it
and it begins to sort of eat you alive
and it's the only thing about you it's
your entire identity
so the same old story we've
the same song we've heard many times
before
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends